hello everyone welcome i
am catching up on the assassin's creed
2022 showcase
um as part of ubisoft forward i know
that the ubisoft youtube channel has
stuff that's like two hours long i don't
really know what that was
um i'm only watching this 30 minute
assassin's creed specific highlight
i've not seen any news from it
i do know
unrelatedly effectively that they have a
game
maybe i shouldn't say it in case it's
not in this never mind i know about
setting it but i'm coming in
um but i imagine it's in this
and
yeah i was intending to stream this live
but i had another power outage so that's
all stopped now thankfully it seems like
things are back to normal but uh this
week it's just
power issues it has been happening um so
let's just jump into it let's watch it i
don't really know what to expect
i used to be a huge assassin's creed fan
and now i would say like
middling um
i'm not gonna not be interested in the
franchise and where it changes and where
it's going and i think ubisoft's a very
interesting company to watch in terms of
games industry trends because they're
very good at predicting them
but it's not like i'm holding out
eagerly are waiting for anything just um
interested just interested that's pretty
much it
so let's do it
that's too loud
out there
okay and i can make myself smaller
[Music]
i loved the
like og
ezio era so much
so much
oh thank you tim
i will use that to buy banjo a treat i'm
ready for this
of course you are
come on don't be shy
don't let the fancy suit impress you
don't let a thousand fancy suits impress
you
i don't know why
choose the greatest enemies
the captain
sorry mate
the emperor
the boss's boss
and make even greater friends seeing it
all like this does like really
put it into perspective how big this uh
friendship actually
is a revolution
it's like i always feel this like burn
though because i was so into
the law of assassin's creed one and two
go too fast i like
obsessed over what the glyphs meant in
ac
and
the people who came before and all that
stuff and it just like kind of
disappeared
i was so set on that journey of having
assassin's creed one and then assassin's
creed
and then what seemed to be a setup for
assassin's creed 3 to be like mostly
outside of the animus in the real world
taking on the templars
um
that it was like probably like my first
adult like betrayal from a franchise
i'm danny wallace here in our top secret
hideout where i'll be bringing you some
sneak peeks special guests and sharing
some very exciting updates on all things
assassin's creed you will not want to
miss this today i am joined by a true
expert assassin's creed's senior
community developer ubisoft's own alice
terret welcome to the show alice can you
believe it's been 15 years thank you so
much danny i cannot believe it's been 15
years
15 years very close to my heart because
i'm in it i'm lucky enough to voice sean
hastings who first appeared back in
assassin's creed 2. now sean sounds
exactly like me which may give you
something as to the limits of my acting
range this year we are celebrating 15
years since the release of the first
assassins creed it's been an amazing
like three a lot yeah john what i'm
saying is not that i didn't like three
it's taken out three wasn't what i
wanted
in terms of the law that they had set up
and then basically burned down between
um
unforgettable characters make it a
different breath taking locations or to
make it a future it was really set up to
be like in my opinion one of the best
it's been a phenomenal sci-fi trilogy
ever not just in video games like ever
it was such a good setup i was so hooked
um and then that all kind of disappeared
because they were like you should end up
truly celebrate with you need to make
more of these we know that you've been
dying to find out what's next first it's
not like they wrapped it up poorly they
just didn't wrap it up just on that
subject sound a lot like you're about to
announce a new game or something and i
am about to announce a new game i just
thought it'd be nice things i'm here so
anyways uh it's time to discover what
we've been crafting in the shadows i
really like the origins
i have roll the trailer um
new game
are you ready to give up who you once
thought you were i am
this isn't the game i was expecting
ready to sacrifice everything your
health clothes
i recognize that voice actor from
collock
rpg uh hyper rpg
thing i played a character on
are you ready to leave your life behind
and walk the path of shadows
i am
i mean this looks beautiful but
obviously it's cinematic really
but yeah it's also not the game i'm
expecting
then out of the dark you will come into
the light
[Music]
this looks very
similar to previous games
almost surprisingly considering how
different the most recent two have been
you will return to the dark the greek
game and the norse game
never forget the tenets you have sworn
to uphold
[Music]
stay your blade from the flesh of the
innocent
because we're getting a lot of
perspectives
and there's just a lot of combat is this
like a multi-player
or am i just way overthinking it
or is it just like a much more like
streamlined combat focused
actually
from this day forward
you are
a hidden one
[Music]
this is definitely like very nostalgic
to watch like it really feels like the
older games
interesting
that's a single-player game thing
better when you put down the dead body
well will you look at that assassin's
creed mirage i we we knew about it tell
us more about this
narrative director sarah
thank you so much for coming thank you
for having me sarah we just had a little
glimpse of mirage what can you tell us
about this latest and very special
assassin's creed adventure okay so it is
just another single player we go back to
the roots of the series it's been 15
years as you know and we wanted to go
back to the action adventure game as you
know narrative driven game so less open
world focusing on stealth parkour and of
course assassinations
now i've been playing a lot of valhalla
recently and from watching that trailer
i couldn't help but notice bassem
yes you're right it's bassim it's 20
years before valhalla so it's a young
version
coming from a street thief to a master
assassin fantastic and so where does his
kind of adventure
begin
well it begins in baghdad it's the
beautiful magnificent vibrant city of
baghdad that you roamed through the game
and it's um yeah it's a very dense city
where you're going to meet a lot of
different people what makes it more like
the original game she said that but what
makes it more i wonder why um so sarah
what can you tell us that makes mirage
special to you specifically well to me
obviously it's all about the story so as
you saw we have a couple of charismatic
characters
starting from bassim so best name is our
lead character we do have russian that
you spotted oh that's the poster yeah
she's basically
characters like in every assassin's
creed some political leaders for example
but not not just uh we do have a couple
of very very interesting characters in
here
what a setting and what history to get
your teeth into but we're obviously
about exclusives here
have you got any more yes i do good and
did you recognize the voice from the
trailer i did actually can i can i can i
reveal it can i reveal these features
you know
it was the emmy winning actress wasn't
it shore dash it was it was yeah you got
it right good yeah we're thrilled to
have her in the castle she's going to be
portraying russian so she's going to be
the voice of bassim's mentor you serving
the traitor oh cool she has a great
voice very very glad to have her she's
fantastic such a recognizable voice
which is why i recognize that of course
well he's doing a really good job to
catch up with shorey earlier and she had
this very special message
a lot of actors can't be host it doesn't
like transfer well but he's doing a
i will be voicing roshan my seems mentor
in assassin's creed mirage
when ubisoft approached me to voice this
character i was immediately seduced by
roshan's strong personality and her
backstory she's a true warrior who
fights for justice
and protects her fellow hidden ones at
all costs
she is loyal and honest but keep her
former self behind a shroud of mystery
and of course the fact that she is a
mature woman from persian origins made
her resonate even more with my own story
and background
playing such a character is a unique
opportunity that i could not miss i hope
you will love her as much as i do it's a
real pleasure for me to collaborate with
the assassin's creed brand and play one
of the main characters in such hmm i
wanna i just wanna know more her voice
is awesome and i could listen to her
talk forever
i think you appreciate that really means
a lot but i i wanna know what they mean
by it being more like ac one or like the
anniversary
sincerely
i like her i like her a lot she's cool
what a nice message what a recognizable
voice as well just instantly and she
seems thrilled to be part of this yeah i
think she is really that's good a
welcome addition to the assassin's creed
world so finally
obviously the question everyone wants to
know
when can we get our hands no i i wanted
to know
what specifically it makes it more like
a second if you pre-order now you also
get the exclusive portion of your side
questions is it a 80-hour game
collector's case available for pre-order
can we tone that back up it includes a
figurine of bassium and other exclusive
surprises that you will love
thank you sarah for being with us today
thank you for having me thank you very
much yes it looks fantastic right we'll
be dropping more exclusive news from the
world of assassin's creed very shortly
but first we wanted to celebrate the
last 15 years of assassin's creed it
feels like it's been longer though
assassin's creed feels like it's been
around my whole life how weird of this
great one's a retro game now my god
out of the dark you come into the light
from the light
you will return to the dark
are you prepared to travel the eagle's
path
welcome aboard
it's prizes plunder and adventure ahead
this is cool to see
we are all different
but our creed will unify us
[Music]
do you regret your decision
to live as an assassin for so long
i do not remember making this man it's
so funny seeing these back-to-backs like
even origin has aged chose me
[Music]
what is the man but the some of his
memories we are the stories we live
the tales we tell ourselves
who is desmond
kills me it hurts as his custom makes me
sad
wrong even happy
to folly on the orders of a single
madman
but act according to our own
collective madness i really liked him
[Music]
from darkness we have come and in
darkness we shall stay
we are
the hidden ones
[Music]
the focus on cosplayers is cool
it is a good life we need
the best
god i love you so much
hey thank you
means a lot
they actually asked me to be part of the
assassin's creed documentary memories
didn't have time to film it jump back in
and just play through the whole series
again would have been cool but yeah to
continue the celebrations we also have a
new documentary what they're referring
to which gives a behind-the-scenes look
at the last 15 years of assassin's creed
let's take a sneak peek
[Music]
for me assassin's creed represents my
whole
video game in the carrier
it's really like where i learned my job
where i grew
in my job
that was really the game that showed to
me hey you gotta step it up but like you
gotta move on from the ps2 and i fell in
love ever since
universe video is
more important assassins creed
especially in those early days showing
people what could be done in this kind
of broad open space just like climbing
pretty goddamn iconic i remember looking
at this world and being like oh wow i've
never done this in a video game before
we're always looking for the next
assassin's creed no matter which one is
your favorite you'll always be tied to
it because of just how connected they've
kept you in from the beginning it's not
just a game it has a
philosophy behind it it's a universe
it's not just a single setting in a
single time but it's different settings
at different times it's like a narrative
universe that uh comes to life
the logo is really cool the little 15. i
only just noticed that how neat
[Music]
well that looks worth a watch to me
where can we see it is it somewhere on
the internet yes it will be on the
internet uh you can catch it on the
ubisoft and gtv youtube channels but
don't go anywhere just yet no so back to
business and i've just finished the dawn
of ragnarok expansion for assassin's
creed valhalla i had a great time but i
would like some more yep that's one of
our most ambitious expansions to date
but danny if you want more i've got
great news as we have more content
coming to assassin's creed valhalla i
feel like they're supporting valhalla a
lot
i wonder if it's one of the more i'm
gareth glover popular director on
assassins recently valhalla's post
launch
since launch we've continued to create
new and exciting content for our
community to enjoy
they're the only games i haven't played
oh i never played any of the like spin
off games such as haven't played
valhalla and i didn't play syndicate
mastery challenges and more recently the
roguelite forgotten saga today i'm
excited to announce that in a few months
time we will also be launching the last
chapter so let's take an exclusive first
look
[Music]
odin
i feel you close
[Music]
i did not know she sounded like that
memories stretching far into the past
i have done all i can for my people
it is time to say goodbye
and set forth for distant shores
and new adventures
fascinating
evil grapples with odin's memories
that's something she's hot unfamiliar to
me
where will this new conflict take you i
wonder
yeah i intentionally didn't uh play
syndicate just to disrespect austin
it's the one you worked on
the fact that the ac unity daughter for
notre dame is being used to help rebuild
this blows my mind yeah it's very cool i
mean the attention to detail and some of
this stuff is nuts
like what rockstar does with la
obviously it's not like to scale but the
stuff they do do
often very accurate watch dogs
you could find
basically
with some key characters including some
influential historical ones
we can't wait for you to experience it
back to you danny and alice
i think this is also a pretty good
conference pretty well
no no i'm not no you've been overwhelmed
already but please go on okay well our
next guest i'm interested in mirage
assassin's creed family with a list of
credits including creative director of
assassin's creed syndicate and producer
of assassin's creed odyssey austin
wintour talking about mark alexander oh
my bad yeah
thanks for joining us well thank you
alice it's great to be here and i i love
what you've done with the place thank
you so let's start with our community
can you tell us what makes assassin's
creed so beloved by our global community
well at ubisoft our mission as a company
as expressed by eve is to enrich the
lives of players on assassin's creed we
have a very clear take on that mission
assassin's creed valhalla has micro
champions
as we immerse players into the richness
of our shared past
what makes ac different though is this
kind of unique mix between historical
accuracy and contemporary codes like it
is a cool mix and when you put all that
together
it gives you the chance to embody iconic
characters to live powerful fantasies
all the while immersed in intriguing uh
historical settings it's amazing uh so
how will this create evolve in the
coming years well we're going to double
down on our passion for history as we
explore the past with courage
we strongly believe that
history can be the most powerful and
eye-opening source of entertainment
and our teams and the history stuff they
do is cool i guess the problem with
assassin's creed where it's at now is
like
that again i was very burned by them
just killing off the desmond thread
completely and just dumping that in the
trash when i was so invested don't worry
we're going to keep telling gran
so that viewers and players alike can
feel that it's it's just been so long
that they just feel so similar now i
think i love that
tough thing
and about using history as a playground
what an incredible thing to be able to
use but the history stuff is really cool
so i'm very happy to announce today our
very first open world assassin's creed
game for mobile
it will feature all the iconic
assassin's creed gameplay but optimize
for an experience on touch controls and
i just can't wait to tell you more about
the story and the setting let's take a
look at the trailer hmm
i'd love to see that always love to see
that
okay this is the one that i knew about
uh
[Music]
okay no it isn't
i was like the one i knew about was not
in china brand new assassin's
that's actually very impressive for a
mobile game matt can you tell us a
little bit more about the features but i
was like it doesn't look as good as i
expected this game to look if it's the
thing i think it is your own character
you'll get the chance to do things like
park i did play one the great wall
assassin's creed muggle game at like a
preview event once but i actually liked
it but i'm still just not on mobile i've
heard the secrets of vastness and
clearly that industry has some very
exploited that gave me my next question
issues so mac many of us know that i've
said this before i'm going to say it
again you should expect every game
studio ever to go mobile well it's still
early in the development but i can
confirm there's nothing we can do about
being the netflix series with ubisoft
film and television netflix man
everybody's really going into insanely
runner jeb stewart it's going to be an
epic jar bending a live action
adaptation of our video game series your
last film did not go down great thing we
have in development with netflix we also
have a new mobile game and development
for their platform not codename james so
you're doing quite a lot with netflix
and just out of interest there's no
reason for me to ask this this is just
this is just curious a lot of people
probably want to know who who's the
casting director for that
why do you want to know no i'm just just
a lot of people have been uh tweeting in
about that well he's really good that's
great i'll talk to you after about that
uh in the meantime let's take a look at
the why don't you trust the mobile game
even a little obvious terrible
monetization the game just won't feel as
good as poor pencil i mean for sure i
generally um generally a gamma i would
agree with you on that
um
i just don't think there's anything we
can do about that
i don't like mobile games i think the
practices that they get away with
um that did not look good uh
should be
criminalized in some cases they need
reform it's not good
[Music]
but they also
are a reality
it's just there's just too much money in
mobile
well the wider world i don't play
assassin's creed there and look we've
had a lot of surprises today i think
that's fair to say but in the grand
tradition of certainly
mack i think you might have saved the
biggest one for last this year that's
right believe it or not i've got more
things to show to you so how about we
take a leap of faith into the future
again and what about southern infinite
that's a real thing right it wasn't just
a like a leak
they didn't announce that didn't they
okay this is the one i knew about
and thus was hoping to see but i wasn't
sure
if it was going to be revealed
wait no hang on is this also a mobile
game why do you call it codename bread
well i think that's what you call big
news
i mean there's a lot of stuff in there
that i think from your point of view
certainly the community the fans have
been asking for for a long time so mac
tell us more well this is code name red
our next premium flagship title and the
future of our open world rpg games on
assassin's creed
it is being developed by you there's
something really weird
about i don't know if this is just me
so i knew about um an assassin's creed
game being developed in uh being
set in japan i'd known about that for a
while um
there's something really weird about at
the same time coming out with a chinese
game and a japanese game and calling
them project jade and project red when
every other game has like a full title
are they tie-ins
that has to have been intentional
otherwise it's a really strange thing
quebec the studio behind assassin's
creed odyssey under the creative
direction of jonathan zuma
people have been wanting this for a long
time the weighted settings ever on the
franchise feudal japan i wonder if
there's a sushima powerful shinobi
fantasy i mean people have been waiting
for this for a long time and i think
they said that they'd never do it at all
you brought it to them it's amazing
which is good and you're slightly cruel
in that you're teasing me with it i very
much want that you mentioned that
sometimes they're announcing it too
that's gonna be the ages that we're all
up to right now well we have our veteran
team behind assassin's creed valhalla in
montreal the birthplace of assassin's
creed who's been hard at work on a new
flagship title as well it is being led
by creative director clint hawking it is
a very different type of assassin's
creed game
and i believe you may have brought so
we've got we've got
code name jade which is a mobile game
code name red
which is
like a full single player assassin's
creed game
and then mirage i'm like surprised that
they're doing this this way maybe they
aren't going to have a conference next
year ubisoft doesn't often announce
like we know they're always working on
more than one assassin's creed game but
they don't often do that
i guess maybe it's just because it's a
15th anniversary stream
them just seems like a weird choice
oh they're just project names they
haven't picked yet i guess then why
would they do that
why would they even say anything
i don't know
like why not just say like unnamed
because it suits the franchise that
things would be like code name whatever
you know
[Music]
i mean this is cool
okay so they are just all
actually code names well the surprise
surprises just keep on coming what can
you tell us about this project well this
is code name hexay and i can't wait for
our fans to tear apart that trailer and
find out all its secrets yeah absolutely
and work out the code now you guys have
always got code names for stuff there
was um was it a year ago there was
code name infinity
wary with that well that's a great oh so
they are just clarifying that it is a
little bit more about project infinity
uh today okay is not a game per se it's
going to be the single entry point that
sounds like nfts
that's what that sounds like franchise
not a game it's a transformative website
kind of like a time machine
exactly yeah he doesn't say anything
like that he is going to be a hub that
will uh all our different experiences oh
boy our players together in meaningful
ways oh that's where nfts come in oh
they're doing it question if you're
connecting players and there's more than
oh god people will be thinking are we
talking multiplayer
well danny it seems we can't hide
anything from you
we're actually investigating how we will
bring back standalone multiplayer
experiences into the assassin's creed
universe
some of the multiplayer was really fun
infinity so the infinity hub is just
like a different version of you play or
whatever it is at some point because you
look for assassin's creed specifically i
bet you this is where there's an nft and
you get a shirt and you can use it in
all three
i can't wait to that's really what it
sounds like joining us today and sharing
all this incredibly exciting news well
thank you danny thank you alice it's
been a pleasure to be here and to be
finally able to share all these great
things that we have coming for our fans
so to sum up there are a lot of exciting
things to look forward to let's remind
ourselves of everything you can expect
from now onwards
this year we will see the release of the
last chapter to aval's story what are
you saying
valhalla then in 2023 we'll see the
release of the next big title assassin's
creed mirage set in baghdad and
following the story
from street thief to master assassin
then it's time for the long-awaited
setting of feudal japan with assassin's
creed codename red and as mack announced
there will also be a very different type
of experience with assassin's creed
codename hexagon that's it in the coming
years we'll see the launch of the new
platform assassin's creed infinity
connecting players to the games so it's
like it's going to be like a launcher
you play but i'm so sure that's going to
be how they bring it
they keep trying assassin's creed code
named jade and of course the release of
our live-action series in partnership
with netflix so loads to come but then
my friends i'm afraid it's all we have
time to really in this very special i'm
just impressed by the amount of news
that they have three showcase now before
i get too comfortable in our hideout and
end up slipping into my ezio cosplay as
normal i just want to thank everyone for
joining us today and making this first
ever showcase so special plus of course
a big thank you to our guests and i
shouldn't do this alice but you know in
the spirit of wrapping up what's the one
thing you're most looking forward to
that's a very tricky question we've seen
so many amazing things um i'm gonna pick
a few okay i will choose mirage um the
netflix series and also feudal japan is
that okay that's fine great well that's
basically everything remember that you
can pre-order mirage now you know the
meantime you can jump back into valhalla
to prepare for aval's last chapter which
is exactly alice what i'm going to do
while we pass back to ubisoft forward we
will see you next time
bye-bye
i enjoyed this in terms of like
getting actual news that's more than a
year out um
which you know people like go back and
forth on all the time um
i think it's a good call for ubisoft in
this case i liked their presenters a lot
i like the style of this showcase
and i would have liked to have seen more
detail about mirage i'm sure they had it
in like a separate part of this i know
this is only just a small chunk
that i'm watching at the assassin's
creed showcase where they actually had a
full ubisoft forward um
because i'm certainly interested in
assassin's creed going back to its roots
in that like i liked origen like i said
i liked that game a lot and i liked what
was different about it but then when
that formula has existed in three games
now it's like
now that formula needs a reset
[Laughter]
code name hexy is totally a witcher
inspired thing i mean it definitely
seemed like it had some horror elements
um
don't know what it is i wonder what he
meant by like waiting for people to
figure out
to analyze the trailer i wonder if like
there's some secrets in there or
something i'm just not up to date with
assassin's creed anymore really
we got the news they celebrated the
anniversary for what it was supposed to
do i think the ac showcase did what i
had to do i agree
yeah
yeah and it was like that 30 minutes
went by pretty quick um
besides
but uh yeah thank you all for watching
uh again excited i can do youtube
streams again even if
my power has not been letting me this
week but hopefully stuff will work for
tgs that one more depends on my schedule
for work because they're such weird
times so
thanks for joining me everybody
um hopefully have another one of these
this week
i appreciate you hanging out
have a wonderful night